І в Україні, і в Німеччині вакцинація дітей
офіційно є питанням доброї волі батьків.
Проте в Україні дітям роблять значно менше щеплень, ніж в Німеччині.
І в Україні, і в Німеччині існує  календар рекомендованих щеплень.
Серед них профілактика дифтерії, кашлюкУ, правцЯ, кОру, поліомієлІту,
туберкульОзу, гепатиту В, гемофільної інфекції, краснухи тощо.
Вакцинувати дітей в двох країнах починають з різного віку.
В Україні поступово з моменту народження.
В Німеччині на початку третього місяця життя малюка.
Причому перше щеплення у ФРН одразу проти шести інфекцій:
дифтерія, гемофільна інфекція, кашлюк, поліомієліт та правець.
В Україні минулоріч лише сорок шість відсоктів дітей отримали щеплення.
А цьогоріч, наприклад, проти кору вакцинувались чверть дітей,
а від гепатиту В - менше двадцяти відсотків.
Всесвітня організація охорони здоров’я
рекомендує загальну вакцинацію дітей на рівні 95%.
В Німеччині щеплені дев’яносто відсотків дітей.
Жодної юридичної відповідальності для батьків
за відмову від вакцинації дітей в Україні та в Німеччині не передбачено.
Проте  в обох країнах дитячі заклади мають право не прийняти дитину,
яка не отримала профілактичних щеплень.
ФРН пішла далі у боротьбі проти відмови батьків вакцинувати дітей.
На початку червня Бундестаг погодив рішення,
відповідно до якого ясла повинні інформувати заклади охорони здоровя про батьків,
які відмовляються щеплювати своїх дітей.
Цих батьків запрошуватимуть на обовязкову консультацію щодо ризиків їхнього рішення.
Якщо ж вони її ігноруватимуть, отримають штраф дві тисячі п’ятсот євро.
І в Україні, і в Німеччині вакцинацією дітей опікується держава.
В Україні календар щеплень складається наказом Міністерства
охорони здоров’я, яке визначає, які саме вакцини мають отримати діти.
В Німеччині цим займається спецкомісія щодо щеплень
Інституту Роберта Коха у Берліні, який підпорядковується мінохорониздоровя ФРН.
Членів комісії суворо перевіряють на наявність зв’язків з фармацевтичними компаніями,
щоб уникнути будь-яких корупційних схем.
В Україні вакцінація відбувається за державні кошти.
В Німеччині - в межах обовязкового медичного страхування родин.